larry elder joins us now he is a former
candidate for
california governor the one we would
have voted for he's the host of larry
elder show on the epic times happy to
see him larry thanks so much for coming
on
so why don't i mean you live in a state
and you tried to fix it yourself but you
live in a state where stores can't stay
open
because they're being looted
i don't ever hear office holders even
mention this
well tucker um excellent monologue as
usual three broad themes the first is
let's talk about the police the police
in city after city whether it's la
whether chicago whether it's new york
they are demoralized by this lie that
they are engaging in systemic racism
against minorities that they're using
deadly force against minorities just
because they're black and they're no
longer engaging in proactive policing
they're not engaging in some form of
stop question and frisk which happened
under the giuliani regime in new york
that caused a deep deep decline in crime
even mayor rahm emanuel the democrat
mayor of chicago even said when he was
mayor that the chicago police had quote
gone fetal close quote meaning they
weren't engaging in proactive policing
the second big theme of course is soft
on crime policies soft on crime
governors like the one in california
soft on crime da's gavin newsom bragged
during kovid that he released 8 000
convicted felons some of them were
violent offenders uh
tucker and the odds are that at least
half of them are going to reoffend you
you have these soft on crime policies
like proposition 47 that allows you to
steal 950 bucks not just a day but per
store and if you get caught
they write you a ticket as a misdemeanor
and you don't go to jail because you got
cashless bail proposition 57 that allows
a bunch of categories of crime to be
called non-violent and they include
assault on a police officer i kid you
not that's non-violent serial arson
nonviolent rape of an intoxicated victim
non-violent and as a result you're
finding a greater chance that the bad
guy doesn't get caught and when the bad
guy knows he's not going to get caught
crime goes up if he knows he's not going
to get convicted crime goes up if he
knows he's not going to get incarcerated
crime goes up they may be crooks but
they're not stupid and finally the one
that few people like to talk about and
you mentioned it in the monologue is the
breakdown of the family you said their
parents plural
are not telling them not to steal that
assumes that there are two parents often
it is the parent or the grandparent 40
of all kids in america today into the
world uh tucker without a father married
to the mother 70 of black kids half of
all hispanic kids 25 percent of white
kids and if you enter the world without
a father married to the mother you're
many times more likely to drop out of
school commit crime
and end up going to jail a young black
man
is eight to ten times more likely to be
murdered than a young white man in fact
murder is the number one preventable
cause of death for young black men
whereas accidents like car accidents and
drownings are the number one cause of
preventable death for young white men
and a lot of this crime is taking place
in the inner city uh in the ghettos and
in the barrios where the father is not
there
i don't know why every republican in the
country wouldn't be running on this i
mean it's just so obvious if this
continues we'll be living in a
completely different place that we don't
want to live in so why don't they say
that out loud
well you know i ran for governor of
california as you pointed out uh it's
one thing to talk about these issues
because it was a central tenet of my
campaign but all the media wanted to
talk about is whether or not larry elder
thought 2020 was stolen i said i'm here
to talk about crime here talk about bad
schools underperforming schools yeah but
do you think 2020 was stolen so i i
cannot
control the filter through which my
message goes they still abc nbc cnn la
times where i was called the black face
of white supremacy they didn't care that
i wanted to talk about crime they wanted
to talk about the fact that i was
republican that i voted for trump and
that had gavin newsom been recalled it
would have been a republican takeover
that's all they cared about and
republicans are outnumbered in
california three to one and california
independents and democrats are
conditioned to loathe republicans and i
and i don't know what it's going to take
it's going to take
like a drug addict you've got to hit
rock bottom and more and more of this
crime is taking place in the suburbs
like beverly hills uh like hancock park
and until unless it happens we're going
to still have the same old policies
pushed by the same old people
yeah make them defend the looting of
7-eleven at every turn can you do you
did this can you defend this and of
course they can larry elder great to see
you thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight